Professor Mark Saltzman:
Okay.
Well, this week we're going to
talk about biomedical imaging.
You know from the first
lectures I mentioned that one of
the biggest advances in
biomedical engineering was the
development of systems for
looking inside the body.
That's what we're going to talk
about this week,
sort of what's the physics
behind some of these systems,
how do they work,
what are their limitations,
and what are the opportunities
that each of them present?
Again, like almost every week's
subject, this one could take up
a whole course.
In fact, there's three or four
courses on biomedical imagining
that are offered here at Yale.
We're just going to scratch the
surface of it,
but what I hope to do is give
you some sense for how these
different modes of imaging work,
why they work,
why they allow you to see
inside the human body,
and then what the limitations
of each particular technology
is.
These are the kinds of
questions that I hope we'll be
able to answer by the end of
this lecture and next lecture.
What is an image?
Most of you could answer that
probably now,
but images come in different
forms.
Why is imaging so important to
medicine?
You probably already know,
either from what you've read in
the past or from your own
experience.
Most of us have had,
at some point,
by the time you're as old you
are, you've had an image taken
of your body,
a medical image,
usually an X-ray.
You know something about why
it's so important,
but we'll try to amplify on
what you already know.
What technologies are available?
We're going to survey the
different techniques that can be
used and that are used most
commonly.
It's a very rapidly developing
field and almost every year
there are new innovations in
imaging,
sometimes even new methods that
are introduced,
and that change the way we can
see inside the body.
I'm going to talk about sort of
a snap shot of what's available
now, and as I said,
illustrate or talk about what
some of the problems are or
challenges with each,
what are the limitations in
particular.
An image is a visual
representation of some
measurable property of a person,
an object, or a phenomenon.
We're going to be thinking
about medical imaging,
so we're going to be thinking
mainly about images of people.
Images can be formed and
displayed in different ways
depending on properties of the
object and properties of the
imaging system that you're using
to create the image.
You're familiar with certain
kinds of images,
you've all probably taken a
photograph with a camera.
Photography has changed
dramatically since you were
born, it used to be all on film
and now it's almost all on
digital.
These are different ways of
capturing the same thing.
A photograph is a
representation of what you can
see, it's a representation of
how visible light reflects off
of objects.
So, you see the outlines of the
objects, and their colors,
and their textures,
but it's basically a
representation of how visible
light is interacting with some
object.
An X-ray,
on the other hand,
shows you something that you
can't see on your own.
It allows you to see inside the
body.
This is because it's not using
visible light which bounces off
of objects like us,
but it's using X-ray radiation
which is able to penetrate the
body.
By taking a picture of how
these particular forms of
electromagnetic radiation called
X-rays,
by taking a picture of how it
penetrates through the body,
you can get an image that
represents something about
what's inside.
The challenge is to know,
because you understand the
physics of the radiation,
in this case X-rays,
and you understand the
equipment that's used to collect
the image,
you should be able to interpret
from your understanding of those
things, what it is that you're
seeing inside the body.
Of course, television is a
different kind of image
presented in a different way,
but another image of something
that we can already see.
Two kinds of imaging
really, images that represent to
us maybe not exactly the way we
see it but things that we can
see,
and images that represent to us
things we can't see but put it
in a form that we can interpret.
So, that's just what this says
here, that some images you're
just trying to collect and
record what it is that you can
see so that you can look back at
it later and remind yourself of
what it was that you saw.
Other imaging systems are
really transducers,
they're converting something
that you can't see into
something that you can.
We talked about transduction
several weeks ago now.
We talked about cell
communication and the concept of
transduction converting one kind
of a signal into another.
In this case,
converting a signal that
measures something you can't see
but converts it into something
that you can see.
To understand this,
I have to review for you
something that most of you
probably already know,
at least at some level,
and that's the electromagnetic
spectrum.
This is a representation of the
variation in properties of
electromagnetic radiation.
Certain forms of
electromagnetic radiation are
apparent to us because our
retinas can detect it.
That's the visible part of the
spectrum which I've shown here.
Now, what this shows is the
entire electromagnetic spectrum
arranged on a scale from very
short wavelength up to very long
wavelength,
and these are in centimeters.
The visible part of the
spectrum is around a micron or
so, or slightly less than a
micron.
It's around 400 nanometers to
700 nanometers is the visible
spectrum.
Now, why is this visible
spectrum?
Because when radiation with
this wavelength hits your eye,
it makes a change in the cells
inside your eye and allows your
retina to make an image.
It's only light of those
particular wavelengths that can
interact productively with this
particular special biological
object called the retina and
that's all the light that we can
see.
There's electromagnetic
radiation of all different
wavelengths outside of the
visible spectrum.
In fact, one of the things you
should notice here is that the
visible spectrum is only a small
piece of the entire spectrum of
electromagnetic radiation.
You know this already.
There are longer wavelengths,
there's longer wavelength
radiation called infrared.
It has wavelengths that are
longer than the--in the visible
spectrum.
You can't see these but some
cameras can see infrared.
That's how if you--when you
watch the films from the war in
Iraq where they have these sort
of heat visualization goggles,
they're looking at infrared
wavelengths.
There's something in the
goggles that is sensitive to
infrared light and it converts
it into visible wavelengths
which you can see.
Have you ever seen
satellite pictures where--they
used to do this,
oil companies or electric
companies would take a picture
of neighborhoods from the sky,
infrared.
Infrared radiation is
associated with heated objects,
so the higher the temperature
of an object the more infrared
radiation of a higher wavelength
it emits.
If you take a picture of a
neighborhood at night using an
infrared camera you can see how
much heat is being emitted from
all the different houses.
You can identify ones that
don't have enough insulation,
for example,
or ones that are wasting heat
because they're emitting it at a
higher temperature.
These are some examples of
using a wavelength that our eye
can't detect but getting
information from it.
You also are familiar with
ultraviolet radiation,
so these are wavelengths that
are shorter than the visible
spectrum.
Shorter than the part of the
spectrum that you can see,
but you can experience the
effects of electro--of
ultraviolet radiation.
If you're out in the sun too
long, your skin turns red,
and you get a sunburn.
That's because your skin
absorbed ultraviolet radiation
created a change in the cells of
your skin.
Different biological effect,
you're seeing it in a sense.
You're only seeing it where the
sun hit not where your body was
in shadow, but you can detect
that radiation that way.
If we look at the whole
spectrum, I'm going to go back a
slide now, and this was arranged
with the long wavelengths up at
this end,
the short wavelengths down at
this end, the other picture is
arranged in just the opposite
way with the long wavelengths
down at this end,
radio waves,
microwaves, infrared waves,
the visible spectrum,
ultraviolet X-ray and gamma
ray.
These are long wavelengths
preceding to shorter
wavelengths.
As the wavelength changes so
the does the frequency.
They're inversely related,
so as the wavelength goes down
the frequency goes up.
The frequency is related to how
much energy these waves contain.
The short wavelength,
X-rays, and gamma rays carry
high amounts of energy.
Ultraviolet rays carry more
energy than visible rays.
Frequency goes up as wavelength
goes down, and so does the
energy of the radiation.
This diagram here shows you
roughly how big is the
wavelength.
For radio waves these are very
long waves that are the size of
buildings or bigger than people.
Microwaves are shorter,
they're the size of an insect;
infrared waves shorter than
that, the size of a pinpoint.
The visible rays,
the ones that our retina can
detect are about the size of
cells.
Bacteria, for example,
or protozoa;
ultraviolet rays the size of
molecules, and then X-rays and
gamma rays are sub-molecular,
they're subatomic in size.
Because of that they have
special properties and they can
actually change atoms.
When X-rays and gamma rays
are absorbed into materials
because their wavelengths are
smaller than the wavelengths of
atoms,
or nuclei, they can actually
interact with atoms and nuclei.
One of the things that X-rays
and gamma rays can do that other
rays don't is ionize an object.
They can actually eject
electrons from the atoms inside
of a material and create ions.
The ions that they create are
often reactive.
This is what makes these short
wavelength, high energy forms of
radiation, biologically
hazardous because they are in
the category called ionizing
radiation.
When they hit your body they
can produce changes,
in particular,
produce atoms--or ions from
atoms.
These ions can further react;
sometimes they even react with
DNA inside cells and cause
mutations in DNA as a result of
chemical reactions that occur.
Because of this we want to
limit the exposure of our bodies
to things like X-rays and gamma
rays.
I'm going to talk about,
in the course of the lecture
today and tomorrow,
many of the ways that X-rays
and gamma rays are useful for
medical imaging.
That's not surprising because I
already say these are short
wavelength, high energy forms of
radiation that can penetrate
through objects fairly easily.
Things that penetrate are
useful imaging what's inside.
The disadvantage of their
penetration is that they can
also create ions and biological
damage so we'll keep that in
mind as we go through.
You know that not only ionizing
radiation causes biological
damage.
I also mention the biological
effects of over exposure to
ultraviolet light,
which you've probably all
experienced through sunburn or
some other over exposure.
These aren't the only kinds of
rays that can have a biological
effect, but they're the ones
that we're most concerned about.
Questions about that?
This is probably a picture that
you've seen before,
if not I encourage you to
review sort of the physics of
the electromagnetic spectrum.
Let's talk about X-rays and
that is the form of medical
imaging that's been around for
the longest.
Before X-rays,
as your chapter in your book
describes, physicians and
doctors relied on hand drawings.
They would draw things so that
they could describe what they
saw to others,
or so they could remember.
If a patient came in and had
something abnormal they might
draw a sketch of it in your--in
their notebooks so they would
remember how it looked for next
time.
Photography changed that
because you could take pictures
of things and you could remember
them without drawing.
But we still couldn't look
inside the body.
Well, you could but not really
very well on living people.
A lot about what we knew about
the inside of the body was from
the science of dissection and
looking inside the bodies of
cadavers,
people after they've died and
learning about their anatomy
that way.
We knew something about that
but we weren't able to look
inside a living body.
This--Wilhelm Roentgen
changed that and Roentgen was a
physicist who discovered that
X-rays could penetrate through
solid objects.
He announced that discovery in
1895, he did an experiment which
is shown in a diagram in your
book, where he put objects in
front an X-ray source.
He was able to show that these
X-rays would pass through the
object and he could detect them
on the other side with a film.
Here's two useful properties of
X-rays, one is they can
penetrate through solid objects;
the second is that they can
expose film.
Film, like photographic film,
is sensitive to X-rays.
Because of this,
then you can imagine taking a
picture of how these rays pass
through a solid object.
Now, the other thing that's
interesting about X-rays is that
they pass through some solid
objects better than others.
The more dense the object is,
the less radiation,
X-ray radiation that passes
through.
If you expose an X-ray beam on
an object that's solid at some
parts and hollow in the others,
X-rays are going to pass easily
through the hollow part and not
so easily through the solid
part.
The amount of X-ray radiation
that goes through an object is
related to the density through
which that X-ray penetrated.
It's these properties that made
it good for taking images.
By--after he discovered that
X-rays could penetrate through
objects, it didn't him very long
to say well if it penetrates
through solid objects like
bricks and boards,
maybe it'll penetrate through a
person as well and took some of
the first images,
X-ray images of people by
looking at the hand,
for example.
He won the first Nobel Prize in
physics for that discovery.
It was--one of the things
you could take from this,
from the time that he first
announced in 1896 until the time
he won what's come to be known
as the highest prize in science
took only six years.
People recognized immediately
the value of this approach,
particularly this approach for
medical imaging.
Now, the ray that he discovered
we now call the X-ray,
initially it was called the
Roentgen Ray because he was the
one that discovered it.
There are some countries that
still refer to X-rays as
Roentgen Rays,
and so you might hear that
nomenclature if you travel or if
you're reading,
particularly in older textbooks.
How does it work?
Here was the first kind of
experiment that I described
earlier.
An X-ray source here,
the X-ray source is emitting
X-rays in all different
directions.
Some of them would impinge on
this object, and depending on
the density of the material
within inside this object some
of the X-rays would be absorbed
and some of them would pass
through.
In a dense part of the object,
the X-rays would be absorbed,
in a less dense part,
more of the X-rays would pass
through.
If you put a piece of film or
some kind of a detector behind
the object then you could create
basically a shadow.
Just like a shadow when
you're standing on the street
and the sun is up here,
the light doesn't pass through
you, and so what you see on the
ground behind you is the sun all
around but a shadow where your
body did not allow the radiation
to pass through.
In this case you'd see a shadow
of this object.
It could be a more
sophisticated shadow in some
ways, because the X-rays can
penetrate somewhat through dense
material and even better through
less dense material.
The shadow would be light where
there was density in the object
and it would be dark where there
was hollowness or less density
in the object.
Make sense?
In this way,
an X-ray is a shadow,
it's an inverse image of the
density through which the X-ray
passed.
The diagram over here shows
you a more sophisticated setup
and the kind of setup that's
used for X-ray imaging in
patients.
You have an X-ray source and so
X-rays are emitted from this
source.
If you didn't confine those
X-rays in some ways they would
be emitted in all directions.
You confine it so that X-rays
are only emitted from one side.
You let that pass through a
filter because these sources of
X-ray generation are not
perfect, they generate waves of
different wavelengths.
So, through a filter that only
lets X-rays pass through,
through a device called a
collimator.
A collimator is a physical
object that basically just
straightens out a beam.
If I had a source of
radiation here and it was
emitting X-rays they would
radiate in all directions.
I could put something that was
X-ray dense behind it and now
they would emit to the front.
What I would like is if I'm
going to take an image of
someone, if I want to take an
image of me for example,
I would like all those X-rays
to pass straight through me so
that I knew what direction all
of the rays were traveling.
When I tried to interpret what
was on the film there'd be a one
to one correlation between where
the X-ray hit the film and where
it went through my body.
If I've got X-rays coming from
all different directions,
then that's going to blur the
image.
You need to straighten it
out so the X-rays go in one
direction and that's what a
collimator does.
It's shown as a hole here but
really it's a sheet with many
small pinholes and these
pinholes only allow X-rays to go
through if they're going in the
right direction.
Ones that come at an angle like
this are going to bounce off,
but X-rays that come straight
through are going to pass
straight through and hit the
object.
The object is the patient,
so I'm standing here,
and there's something behind me
that's going to detect the
X-rays that pass through.
That something behind is this,
there's a grid also to prevent
scatter, to only collect the
X-rays that are passing in the
right direction because some of
those X-rays might have been
deflected as they passed through
the object through me.
I only want to collect the ones
that are going in one direction,
so that I will know where the
anatomical object they pass
through are.
That hits a fluorescent screen,
and the fluorescent screen is a
special material that emits
light when X-rays hit it.
An X-ray hits the fluorescent
screen, it generates a lot of
light right in that spot,
and this detector detects the
light.
The fluorescent screen
amplifies the X-ray signal.
Several photons of X-ray hit,
they generate fluorescence,
and they expose the detector.
Now, in the old days this
used to be really film,
X-ray film, photographic film
that was sensitive to X-rays and
you would--the detector was
really a piece of film that you
would take out of the machine.
You would develop it with
chemicals, the same way you
develop--any other kind of
photographic film.
Now, there are detectors that
are electronic and so you can
detect things electronically
without film.
If you have an X-ray though you
probably--if you have one at
home an X-ray that your parents
gave you,
say you're going off to college
take your chest X-ray--anybody
bring one?
Well, if you did it would be
probably a real piece of film.
X-rays are formed from high
energy radiation,
an inverse shadow is created
because X-rays pass through less
dense areas easier.
What's it going to pass through
in the body if you do a chest
X-ray of my chest,
for example,
where will the X-rays pass
through the most easily?
Well, they'll pass through the
lungs, the lungs is primarily
air;
the lungs is air and tissue but
it's mainly air spaces.
So, what you see is dark here,
the less dense regions are the
lungs where nothing much
interfered with the X-rays
passing through the body.
Had to pass through skin,
soft tissue,
some muscles,
and then primarily through air.
Where the image is light here
those are regions that absorbed
most of the X-ray,
so not many of the X-rays got
through to the film in back of
me.
Those areas appear lighter,
so this bone,
the clavicle appears light,
the ribs appear light,
the bones of the ribcage appear
lighter.
What's this object here?
In the chest over on this side
big--the heart.
Why does the heart appear light
on this image?
Well, it's not bone,
it's not as dense as bone,
it's muscle,
it's soft tissue but it's also
filled with water,
a lot of water.
It's a three dimensional
object, and so for X-rays to
pass through whole three
dimensional object,
a lot of the X-rays get
absorbed.
It's a thicker object than this
bone, and so even though it's
not as dense as bone it appears
whiter here because it's
thicker.
X-rays have to pass through
more of it in order to get to
the other side.
The thicker the region it has
to pass through,
the more opportunity for those
X-rays to be absorbed.
The diaphragm--what do you
think are these scattered sort
of white things all around here,
all around the side here?
Well, first what's this object
that comes up that's sort of off
to the side?
Here's the heart,
something comes up--the aorta,
the aortic arch is here.
Remember from our pictures of
the heart?
You can't see it entirely
because behind it is another
white object that's sort of the
midline here,
that's the bones of the spine.
In this region here,
they're all superimposed so you
can't really tell how much of
this absorption comes from the
aortic arch and how much of it
comes from the spine.
This is one problem with
X-rays, that you're not seeing a
three dimensional image of the
chest in this case;
you're seeing a projected image.
You're only looking in one
direction, really,
and you're seeing a projection
of all the things that the
X-rays could pass through.
I can't tell for example if the
aortic arch is in front of or
behind the spine.
I can't even tell where the
boundary them of are because
it's all just--they're absorbing
X-rays and so I can't see it.
What if I wanted to look at
this in more detail,
or I wanted to distinguish what
part of this is this aortic arch
and what part is the spine,
how would I change the imaging?
Sarah?Student:
[Inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Yeah,
you could ask the patient to
turn to the side and you could
then do the same measurement
this way.
Now, you'd see another
projection but you see a
projection from another angle.
So, you would be able to
differentiate what is different
in this direction.
You might do it obliquely,
you might ask the patient to
turn a little bit sideways or
turn the other way.
By putting together several
different images taken from
different angles you can learn
more about the three dimensional
aspects of what's inside.
You might be able to see things
that you can't in one image in
one of the other angles.
X-rays are a projection,
a two dimensional projection of
three dimensional object and
that's one of their limitations.
You can get around that a
little bit by asking the--by
moving the object around or
taking images from different
sides.
Another problem with X-rays
is radiation dose.
I mentioned that X-rays were a
form of ionizing radiation.
So, if you're exposed to X-rays
you could be generating ions
inside.
With a normal chest X-ray,
if you only have one chest
X-ray taken every 5 years or 10
years or so, the dose that you
get is relatively low.
Your body has mechanisms for
repairing those--that biological
damage.
Your body has mechanisms for
repairing the kind of biological
damage that's done by ionizing
radiation.
If the dose is low enough the
risk of some permanent kind of
damage is fairly low.
Where there is a risk is if you
have repeated exposure to higher
doses, in which case you're
generating--more ions are being
generated in your body than the
repair mechanisms that are
naturally in place can repair.
Then, you get tissue damage.
One is concerned when
you're using radiation with
limiting the dose that is
delivered on each X-ray.
How could you reduce the dose
here?
How could you reduce the
radiation dose that the patient
receives?
Thinking about how this thing
works, how could you reduce the
dose?
Well, one is you could use the
minimum number of X-rays
necessary to see what you want
to see.
Of course, as you use less
radiation does you're going to
see less on the image.
So you're--the sensitivity is
going to go down.
One of the things you might not
see if you use less radiation
dose you might not see these
other structures here that are
barely visible in this
particular image.
These structures here are
vessels from the pulmonary
vasculature and the bronchi
associated with the lung and you
might care about those,
so you might need a higher dose
in order to see what you want to
see.
So, you can reduce the dose by
reducing the intensity of the
radiation but the cost is you
don't get as high a quality of
an image;
not as useful for a diagnosis.
One could also make
innovations in the machinery.
In particular,
you could make detectors that
are always--that get more
sensitive.
The more sensitive the detector
is the more information you get
per photon or per radiation.
More sensitive detectors allow
you to make better measurements
with less radioactivity.
There have been those
innovations continually over the
years, and so the X-rays that
you would get now are fairly low
dose X-rays without much
apparent risk to you.
You also can limit where the
X-rays hit the body and part of
that's done by focusing;
part of it's done by something
called shielding.
If you were getting a chest
X-ray done they might put an
apron on at your waist.
That apron contains a very
dense material,
and so the X-rays don't
penetrate through below your
waist.
These are all ways that
radiologists use to reduce the
radiation dose to patients.
We talked about being able
to see more by looking at
different angles.
The technology called Computed
Tomography or CT is sort of the
end product of that.
It's trying to design X-ray
machines, and CT machines use
X-rays.
The physics of how you form the
image is exactly the same.
You're generating X-rays and
they're passing through the
body.
What's different is that the
machine allows you to take
pictures at many,
many different angles while the
patient stays still.
Instead of asking the patient
to move from one side to the
other so you can take pictures
at different angles,
you have an X-ray source and a
detector that basically spins
around the patient.
It takes pictures at different
angles, and you use not a broad
beam that's going to expose my
chest all at the same time,
but you use a narrow collimated
beam, a narrow beam that you can
focus and move throughout all of
the angles around the body.
You're not giving sort of a
plane of radiation anymore
you're giving something more
like a line of radiation.
As that line passes through me,
there's going to be absorbance
detected back here depending on
what was in the way of that
particular line of radiation
that was coming through.
Now, any one line doesn't
give you very much information,
but what if you collect those
lines from all around my body?
You can basically see my body
from every angle.
That still is going to be a
complicated set of images.
What if you took 360 pictures
as you spun this thing around my
body, now you've got 360
pictures to look at,
how do you make sense of that?
Well, you couldn't really.
What really made CT possible,
is that mathematicians figured
out mathematical ways for taking
all of these separate images
that are collected as you move
around the body,
and reconstructing an image of
the whole object that must have
been in between.
The mathematical process is
called back projection,
you take a large number of
projected images that are
acquired from all different
angles and you can reconstruct a
picture of what the object must
have looked like that it was
sampling.
Now, because it's a narrow
beam you're doing this in a line
instead of a plane.
And you're spinning it around,
you're really doing a slice
through the body with each
rotation of the device.
If I spin this all around my
body, then I'm basically moving
this line around different
angles and I'm looking at one
slice.
Between here and here all the
way around, and so you can
reconstruct an image of a slice
that might look like this.
The chest X-ray,
a plain of radiation,
shadow of what that produces,
the CT gives you a slice,
a transverse slice of the body,
but it shows you the real three
dimensional structure of what's
inside.
What can you see in this
picture?
Well, here was the spine in
this picture,
is this from the thorax that
contains the lung or is this
from the abdomen that contains
the intestines?
Don't read the bottom of the
picture.
Just looking at it,
it's not the lungs because you
don't see a lot of dark area in
here that would indicate air.
What you see instead are a lot
of soft tissues that sort of
absorb radiation.
This here is the liver,
you can see muscles and bones
of the ribcage which are down in
the abdomen here.
You can see the spine very
clearly, you can see the kidneys
at the back, you can see the
intestines in here.
An experienced radiologist
who's looking at this can see a
lot of information arranged in
the proper three dimensional
way.
Now, this is one slice but
you could do another slice as
well.
You can do that in the machine
because the patient is sitting
still and is moving through the
machine one step at a time.
There's a conveyer belt here
that's bringing the patient into
the machine.
In the machine is this rotating
array of X-ray sources and
detectors.
This part spins around.
So you bring the patient in,
you spin it around,
you collect all the images,
you bring them in a little
father, you spin it around.
Each time each increment that
you move the patient in you're
taking a picture of another
slice,
and so one could take a three
dimensional image of the whole
body.
Now, because you're just
using line sources of radiation
one can reduce the amount of
radiation that with each
individual picture that you take
compared to an X-ray.
But you've got to take a lot of
these pictures,
and so the cumulative dose of
radiation can be significant.
Even though you could take a
full three dimensional of your
body, you might not want to do
that.
You might just want to take a
picture of the slices that seem
to be of interest,
maybe the abdomen,
maybe the chest,
maybe the knee if you're having
a problem with your knee.
CT is commonly used for head
injuries, it's fast,
it's very effective at
detecting blood in the brain for
example.
You can detect that easily.
And for analyzing the structure
of bones, and you know X-rays
are very good for bones.
If you've ever had a broken
bone, then you've probably seen
an X-ray of the bones of your
body.
That's because bones absorb
X-ray radiation,
and so X-rays are very good
ways to detect it.
I think that's where I want to
stop for today.
We talked about X-ray radiation;
I got some slides on here that
say a little bit more about
ionizing radiation.
I put them on there for you to
read because it's not in the
chapters in the book,
but this talks about sources of
ionizing radiation,
a picture of sort of what it is
and some of the biological
effects of ionizing radiation.
It's sort of beyond what I'm
going to ask you about in the
exams or anything,
but I wanted you to have that
information.
Then, next time we're going to
move on and talk about forms of
imaging that don't require
X-rays,
and so don't have the
biological risks of ionizing
radiation.
We'll talk about ultrasound
imaging and MR imaging,
and we'll talk about what I
think is going to be an
important imaging technique of
the future but using light to
image inside the body as well.
Questions?
Good.
Thanks;
I'll see you on Thursday.